in den letzten tagen haben die
ägypterinnen und ägypter über eine neue
verfassung abgestimmt vor drei jahren am
25 januar 2011 begann der aufstand gegen
präsident hosni mubarak dann kam und die
muslimbrüder ans ruder im letzten sommer
schließlich übernahmen das militär unter
general abdel fatah als sie die macht
wir sind die gewinner wer die verlierer
dieser politischen und
gesellschaftlichen umwälzungen die
schweiz hin mit ägyptischen wurzeln die
yasmin el sol but i und der
islamwissenschaftler reinhard schulze
ziehen eine bilanz sind zu gast bei
norbert bischoff berger
war er sympathie wie geht es den
menschen in ägypten drei jahre nach dem
sturz von präsident husni mubarak
drei jahre nach dem sturz von hosni
mubarak ist das land sehr gespalten
obwohl jetzt die verfassung angenommen
wurde die neue verfassung angenommen
wurde mit einer relativ
ansprechenden
wahlbeteiligung aber trotzdem sind die
befürworter und die gegner des neuen
systems auszumachen diese spaltung geht
durch die durch die familien aber
trotzdem an die leute das bedürfnis nach
stabilität und sie häufig spaltung naja
das zum beispiel familien
familienangehörigen nicht gleicher
meinung sind diejenigen die eben das
militär unterstützen die meisten sind es
dann die kinder die söhne die töchter
die anderer meinung sind und das wird
sehr heftig ausgetragen auch unter
freunden zum zum teil aber dennoch ist
jetzt
der wille des volkes oder der
ägypterinnen und ägypter nach stabilität
so groß sind ist auch müde nachdem drei
jahren sie wollen wieder eine
wirtschaftliche ein wirtschaftliches
weiterkommen und so weiter und erhoffen
sich dass jetzt form dieser von diesem
neuen weg der eingeschlagen wurde sie
haben sogar eine position das ist das
militär die andere position
na ja das sind natürlich die
anhänger die anhänger des gestürzten
präsidenten die muslimbrüder die sich
natürlich immer noch
weigern diese neue staatsform oder diese
neue politische situation anzuerkennen
aber es gibt immer mehr auch eine gruppe
man nennt sie der dritte platz zum
beispiel die eben nicht weder für das
militär sind noch für die
muslimbrüderschaft also keine islamisten
und die sich für ägypten einen dritten
weg wünschen die angst haben dass jetzt
jetzige situation mit dem militär im
hintergrund oder bzw im vordergrund
nicht demokratie fördern ist wenn sie zu
hören er schuld sein gespaltenes land
ergibt und sie haben ägypten oft bereich
sie haben phasenweise dort auch gelebt
umwälzungen in den letzten jahren und
spricht von zwei großen politischen
umwälzungen auch revolutionen was haben
sie für ein gefühl wenn sie heute an
ägypten denken
es fällt auf dass in ägypten der
gesellschafts konsens nicht mehr
existiert also ägypten die bevölkerung
endergebnis nicht mehr geschlossen der
meinung dass sie einer gleichen ordnung
angehören dass sie eine ordnung die wir
gesellschaft nennen angehören dass sie
dieselben regeln
zu verfolgen haben sondern viele sind
der meinung dass das was sie persönlich
oder als gruppe als wert empfinden wir
als eigene regel welt für sich
interpretieren und so dass in dem land
eine ungeheure pluralität existiert
dieses früher so nicht gegeben zumindest
nicht im öffentlichen raum nicht gegeben
hat und die pluralität im lande die sich
aber nicht unbedingt den politischen
parteien oder in strukturen abbildet
kennzeichnet jetzt die situation wenn
man nach ägypten reist hat man immer den
eindruck man betrifft sehr
unterschiedliche lebenswelten sehr
unterschiedliche räume bestimmte straßen
hätten alexandria erinnern an wo unter
religiöse gemeinschaften leben da kommt
man praktisch gar nicht mehr rein als
nicht ergibt da nicht in dem viertel
angehöriger oder man gibt in andere
situation in kairo ins kabarett und hört
sich dort die skurrilsten witze über die
zeitgenössische situation in ägypten an
also die welt ist in ägypten so choral
geworden so heterogen geworden dass
selbst manchmal ich den eindruck habe
die ägypterinnen und ägypter übersät
überblicken das land nicht mehr also sie
haben die ihr eigenes land einfach auch
nicht mehr so im griff im verstehenden
im griff so dass sie sich wundern was
alles in diesem land gibt das dann jetzt
zutage getreten ist in den letzten drei
jahren war denn der suchende mubarak
eine einheitliche gesellschaft war keine
einheitliche gesellschaft nur im
öffentlichen das heißt öffentliche blick
war einfach gedeckelt das heißt die
regierung präsentierte ägypten als ein
relativ einheitliches land mit dem paar
islamistischen gefährdungen aber im
grunde sei so etwas wie eine
geschlossene vom volk getragen der
republikanische ordnung wo es eben nur
einen politischen willen gehabt und dass
ich jetzt zusammen geprobt wie seine
neue verfassung da ist es ein leben
insgesamt positive entwicklung
naja also die neue verfassung die trägt
durchaus positive züge das muss man
schon sagen also bezüglich der rolle der
frau zum beispiel da gibt es jetzt
endlich einmal einen artikel der die
gender gleichheit expressis verbis
ausdrückt auch in den obi ja auf dem
papier natürlich also bei den islamisten
hieß es in der verfassung der islamisten
vor einem jahr hieß es also die frau ist
die schwester des mannes also sozusagen
ein an hexel es gibt folter ist zum
beispiel verboten es gibt ein recht des
kindes kinder werden als als individuen
wahrgenommen
es gibt schon fortschritte aber es gibt
natürlich auch schönheitsfehler
natürlich also zum beispiel ganz klar
die rolle des militärs wie sie definiert
ist in diesem in dieser verfassung ist
eigentlich eine institution für sich die
hektik einer staatlichen kontrolle
unterstellt ist der oberste militärrat
hat auch das vetorecht bei der benennung
des ministers also der minister der
verteidigungsminister wird immer ein
militär sein ja und auch die judikative
kontrolliert sich selber und in dieser
ganzen debatte die wir jetzt gehört
haben in den letzten zwei drei monaten
über diese verfassung war meiner meinung
nach waren diese beiden punkte wurden
sie nicht
ausreichend debattiert bzw es besteht
auch hier ein konsens darüber in der
gesellschaft dass das militär der
gerannt ist für stabilität weil die
leute wie das herr schulte schon gesagt
hat
warum sichert sich das sind auch müde
sie haben es satt sie wollen stabilität
und sie erhoffen sich diese stabilität
vom militär diese debatte wurde meiner
meinung nach nicht in einer in einer
freiheitlichen in einer offenen
gesprächskultur geführt sie sind ja in
ägypten aufgewachsen schweizer mit
ägyptischen wurzeln beim 1971 in die
schweiz gekommen
ist dass auch das echo sie sind ja nach
wie vor mit vielen menschen in ägypten
in kontakt dass sie jetzt in diesen
tagen erhalten
na ja wie gesagt also das echo ist sehr
gespalten ich nehme wahr dass es kommt
immer darauf an mit reden und zu tun hat
dass also jüngere leute aktivisten sehr
skeptisch sind über den neuen kurs
hingegen leute das online des alters
ältere die ältere generation sehr daran
glaubt dass ich jetzt endlich eine
stabilität einsetzung vor allem sie
glauben auch daran dass das militär nach
dieser übergangsphase die die das land
öffnen wird für einen demokratischen für
eine wirkliche demokratie
und diese beiden mit diesen beiden
spalten mit diesen beiden ideen setzt
man sich ständig auseinander wobei ich
auch sagen muss dass händler jetzt seit
sehr sehr schwierig war kritik zu üben
also wenn man in einer runde gesessen
ist und wenn man zum beispiel sich
erlaubt hat den generalstab zu
kritisieren oder das vorgehen der
regierung zu kritisieren im übrigen
hätten als der westen dann wurde einem
sozusagen schon
das munter mund gestopft also man es ist
sehr schwierig kritik zu äußern und das
ist natürlich auch etwas was eine eine
debatte in einer demokratie bedingt
durch verschiedene meinungen von außen
schaut das aus dreht sich im kreis
zurück auf platz eins sie sind
islamwissenschaftler sie lehren an das
bett in bayern das heißt sie sind nicht
muslim sie sind beobachter
wissenschaftler wie klingt das für sie
man hat bisschen den eindruck dass zu
sehr der rhetorik des staates und
politischen institutionen gefolgt wird
indem man die situation so kommentiert
wie sie jetzt auf dargestellt wird dass
die leute
sozusagen in einem politischen willen
repräsentieren wollten aber ich glaube
im kern in dieser ganzen revolte in
ägypten ging es gar nicht so sehr und
politik es ging gar nicht um die frage
welche system in ägypten eine rolle
spielt sondern es ging vor allem um die
frage welche lebensmöglichkeiten haben
individuen einzelne der gesellschaft
haben sie die freiheit haben sie die
möglichkeit räume die sie brauchen um
ihre zukunft für sich selbst zu
gestalten sie wollten vielfach einfach
die mauern durchbrechen die ihnen sind
hier an einen eigenen lebensfähigen und
lebensplanungen entgegengestanden sind
ob es heirats beziehungen sind ob es
einfach karriere möglichkeiten sind also
sehr subjektive sehr individuelle sehr
nachvollziehbare gründe die zu dieser
revolte geführt haben und diese gründe
übersetzen sie schlechte politik also es
gibt keine wirklichen politischen
parteien die das abbilden können das
geht auch gar nicht diese vor eine
politische partei während der lage
abzubilden welche karrierehoffnungen
eine generation hat das gilt nicht und
sie haben auch von stabilität gesprochen
das höre ich jetzt auch wieder heraus
vor einem jahr im letzten jahr im sommer
die ablösung von präsident muss sie der
muslimbrüder war das für sie eine
überraschung eigentlich nicht also am
anfang als muss gewählt worden ist wurde
ich gefragt wie lange geben sie muss sie
damals habe ich gesagt anderthalb jahre
ist ein übergangspräsident die
muslimbrüder werden als institution
nicht in der lage sein einen konsens zu
schaffen der die politischen parteien in
ihrer pluralität anerkennt das wären sie
nicht schaffen das war vorhersehbar es
war vorhersehbar dass mussten wurde an
ihrem eigenen system schaltern werden an
ihrer eigenen vorstellung scheitern
werden dass sie sich selbst so
überschätzt haben dass sie tatsächlich
so etwas wie den willen der revolte in
ägypten repräsentieren könnten das taten
sie nicht was haben sie falsch gemacht
sie haben im grunde ihrer moralischen
vorstellungen ihrer wertvorstellungen in
politik in normen und regeln umgesetzt
das heißt also bestimmte vorstellungen
wie das aus ihrer ordnung zu sein habe
haben sie sogar in die verfassung
eingestellt stan bharti hat das
angesprochen was die frauenfrage
anbetrifft arbeitsverhältnisse die
möglichkeit der frau in
arbeitsverhältnisse einzutreten all das
wird plötzlich geregelt dass heißt es
sind politische programme die ihnen die
verfassung hineingekommen sind und das
ist ein konstruktionsfehler einer
verfassung eine verfassung darf nicht
politischen willen einer bestimmten
partei zum ausdruck bringen sondern muss
die pluralität anerkennen auch dass dann
die willensbildung sich bloß im
parlament entfalten kann aber sie haben
gesagt in einem zeitpunkt sind über
diese zweite revolution war die richtige
revolution aber das war ja
das wird natürlich auch so dargestellt
und es war natürlich ich habe selber
achtermann roth unterstützt diese die
rebellion bewegung ich habe in der
schweiz innerhalb der ägyptischen
community unterschriften gesammelt weil
ich auch davon überzeugt war dass die
und immer noch bin dass der politische
islam nicht nur in ägypten auch in
anderen ländern nicht die lösung ist
diese diese ablösung ich selber ich habe
mich damals sehr gefreut ich war ich war
sehr glücklich darüber wie viele auch
linke aktivisten nur was nachher
passiert ist dass es dann das
fragwürdige nicht also dass das militär
das mandat das militär wirklich als
sozusagen willkommen heißt und in die
verantwortung dafür übergibt und sich
zurückzieht eben als säkulare parteien
als linke parteien und sich sozusagen
dem militär voll vertraut dass es diesen
weg diesen übergangs weg leiten wir dass
das ist natürlich das ist wahrscheinlich
nicht so gut herausgekommen aber ich
habe von anfang an auch das unterstützt
diese in diesen übergang die revolution
frisst ihre kinder naja also nach und
nach ist es schon so wenn wir jetzt
schauen dass zum beispiel aktivisten der
ersten stunde
vertreter der sechsten april bewegung
die jetzt übrigens auch dämonisiert
werden also ich hab gestern
vor drei jahren angehen schon angefangen
haben die steigerungen haben vor 2011 er
mobilisiert haben die arbeiterschaft in
mahalla und so weiter die sind jetzt im
gefängnis
und die werden jetzt eher zeit
dämonisiert ich habe gestern
diesbezüglich eine fernsehsendung
gesehen in einem privaten sender also
eine eine dämonisierung eine
ausschaltung eben das was ich vorher
gesagt habe all jene die eben kritisch
sind oder die sich fragen stellen und
eben die sehr wohl auch gegen den
politischen islam eingestellt waren und
dass auch immer in ihren positionen
verkündet haben nicht also was jetzt
stattfindet ist die diese polarisierung
wenn du nicht mit uns bist bist du gegen
uns ja wenn du nicht mit der route des
militärs und der übergang
übergangsregierung ist uns der
verfassung dann bist du entweder ein
muslim brüder oder sympathisiert mit den
muslimbrüdern das ist so die allgemeine
innovative derzeit oder die benennung du
bist ein spion vom ausland oder du
kennst dich überhaupt nicht aus damit du
zu dieser situation ist jetzt
beschreiben geben als dieser macht
ablösung von letzten sommer hervorgeht
haben wir einen beitrag vorbereitet ein
ausschnitt aus der sendung unscharf vom
27 november des letzten jahres der
beitrag von pascal weber fasst die
situation er gibt nach der
machtübernahme durch das militär
nochmals zusammen
unsere armee ist für alle da
dies ist unser held er hat unser land
gerettet
ihr wählt euren präsidenten und ihr sagt
wenn ihr genug habt von ihnen
general sie ist in ägypten in aller
munde im wahrsten sinne des wortes
dankbarer galal die glühende verehrerin
und clevere confiserie inhaberin hat
blitzschnell reagiert und den general
aus schokolade geschaffen
wir haben schoko sie es ohne füllung
dann gibt es die sorte mit krokant
oder mit kardamom
oder mit türkischem kaffee wir
experimentieren mit allem möglichen
ägypten experimentiert auch gerade wohin
führt der general das land
ist er mit seiner armee dabei die
herrschaft der alten garde wieder
einzurichten oder führt er ägypten
tatsächlich richtung demokratie wie er
das verspricht
die ägyptische armee ist neutral sie
wird für niemanden partei ergreifen
niemals
amir abrashi man kennt sie seit vielen
jahren abo hashima war selbst general in
der ägyptischen armee
ich war ein junger offizier und hatte
gerade ein stipendium für die usa
erhalten ich freute mich auf allerlei
abenteuer da kam sie auf mich zu und
warnte mich vor den versuchungen einer
solchen reise das zeigt dass er vor
allem anderen sehr gläubig ist er
rezitierte damals sogar einen spruch des
propheten
gysi der gottesfürchtige
der der seinem volk dient
auch wenn bei der räumung von
protestlern seiner gegner mehr als 1000
menschen sterben
die anhänger des gestürzten präsidenten
muss sie in general cc als feind
die militär sind verräter sie täuschen
das volk sie töten unsere brüder und
schwestern
ein zur militärherrschaft nein zu noch
mehr toten gott wird dich bestrafen sie
ja herr schulze wie schätzen sie
armeechef
ccs ist
politisch schwer zu verorten er war
zumindest eine zeitlang
anhänger einer islamischen partei an
wasser partei und hatte auch einen
fürsprecher gehabt in einem bunten
islamischen intellektuellen in ägypten
er hat also irgendwo auch einen
islamischen hintergrund dann auch eine
keine islamische agenda aber so etwas
wie normen und werte die er zu vertreten
gedenkt die will er auch irgendwie
islamisch begründet sehen das ist aber
nicht in seinem politischen willen
deutlich erkennbar sondern es hat es
nochmal jetzt in der rhetorik von ihnen
in dem ausschnitt gezeigt er will eben
so etwas wie neutralität und darstellen
die armee soll übervater der ägyptischen
gesellschaft sein sollte das über-ich
der ägyptischen gesellschaft seien und
mit dem soll dann auch die gesellschaft
sind wieder anfreunden wieder befrieden
können um auf diese art und weise eine
zukunft für das land zu schaffen und
diese rolle übernimmt er jetzt auch
persönlich er ist sozusagen die
personifizierte gestalt der armee und
inwiefern sehr sich daraus dann auch ein
politischer wille eine als trägerschaft
ableiten dass das wird man in der
zukunft aussehen sie haben also es ist
ja interessant eben die rhetorik die die
angewendet wird also er spricht auf
ägyptischen dialekt meistens in der
regel er hat auch diese so eine sehr
ruhige art zu sprechen bedeutet und was
bedeutet nähe zum volk
es gibt wörter die immer wieder
vorkommen in seinem diskurs er spricht
die leute direkt an ihr seid das
ägyptische volk es ist eine sehr
überladene rhetorik als er mehrpreis das
ägyptische volk für das was geleistet
hat und bezieht sich da immer auf die
revolution vom 25
jänner 2011 er hat auch etwas sehr
väterliches und man muss dazu sagen also
aus den augen der ägypter etwas sanft
väterlich ist aber der dann doch mit
strenge mit strenge sozusagen regiert
und ich glaube dass hier einfach etwas
ist was wir und da spreche ich jetzt
wirklich sehr gut darin natürlich
gelernt haben von kindesbeinen an das
ist die autorität zu respektieren und zu
akzeptieren den nationalen diskurs wir
wachsen auf mit einer nationalen mit
einer nation mit einem nationalen bezug
in der schule singen wir die
nationalhymne es gibt den fahnen groß
nicht es gibt also eine sehr große eine
sehr große wie soll ich sagen diese
liebe zu ägypten dieser diese liebe zum
vaterland ja das ist ein großes thema
und dass jetzt gerade in dieser
auseinandersetzung eben wo eben die
politischen gegner ausgegrenzt werden
zählt damit argumentiert wird nicht also
die muslimbrüder lieben ergibt nicht ihr
seid das volk ihr bestimmt was mit eurem
was mit eurem schicksal passiert das ist
eine rhetorik auf die die ägypter sehr
ansprechen weil sie auch eben das
wirklich sozusagen mit der muttermilch
eingesogen haben und hier eine eine
kritische distanz zu schaffen
das ist die frage wie das funktioniert
sie haben ja schon von einem dritten weg
gesprochen wir sind denn die verlierer
die verliererinnen des ganzen prozesses
zum beispiel die koptischen christen in
ägypten gibt es 90 prozent heißt dass
muslime ungefähr 9 prozent dresden die
neujahrsgottesdienst jedenfalls mussten
bewacht werden
eine zeit lang waren sicherlich die
religionsgemeinschaften und christlicher
religionsgemeinschaften
die verlierer des ganzen spiels aber die
eigentlichen verlierer des spiels sind
natürlich diejenigen die die revolution
vor drei jahren in die wege geleitet
erklärt haben das heißt also die sich
jetzt in keiner art und weise
repräsentiert sehen wieder in der
politischen parteien landschaft noch in
der willensbildung noch eine verfassungs
prozess all die anliegen die in der
revolution zum ausdruck gebracht worden
sind es haben sich nicht nur politik
übersetzen lassen das heißt die sind
sozusagen politisch die verlierer aber
nichtsdestotrotz hat eine gewisse und da
bin ich ein bisschen
etwas anderer meinung hat sich eine
öffnung in der ägyptischen gesellschaft
ergeben eine öffnung die
pluralität zuletzt zwar ist der
nationale discos
übermächtig aber ist hätte ich noch was
anderes in ägypten heute
die ägyptischen intellektuellen auch die
universitäten auch die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
neben zunehmend kenntnis von dem was
ihre eigene gesellschaft eigentlich ist
das heißt sind jahrelang nur als seine
politische wissenschaft aufgetreten sie
haben versucht ihre nation zu
interpretieren und zu diskutieren
ägypten im rahmen des nahost konfliktes
ägypten im rahmen des der der arabischen
welt der islamischen welt all das wurde
in den vordergrund gerückt und man
vergaß eigentlich sich zu vergewissern
in welcher gesellschaft leben wir
eigentlich dass die selbstbeobachtung
ist die selbst auslegung in welcher form
auch die ägypterinnen und ägypter leben
hat im grunde nie stattgefunden und das
ist hat schon deutlich gemacht dass
jetzt sehr viel mehr auf die qualität
dieser 80 millionen menschen die in dem
lande leben geachtet wird es wird
gesehen dass es sender gibt es geht wird
gesehen dass es stadtteile gibt in kairo
wo es überhaupt für einen normalen
ägypter aus kalkar kein zugang gibt wo
millionen von menschenleben den kunden
unterschiedlichster weise mobilisierbar
sind man nimmt also näher sehr viel mehr
kenntnis von dem was dieses eigene
landen ist und dies das land ist nicht
nur nation sondern ist auch eine
bevölkerung sind wirklich objekte
menschen die in ihrem völlig
prahlen dasein ganz unterschiedliche
vorstellungswelt nennen denn die
gewinner
also ich sehe das auch so mit mit
entwickelten eine sehr pluralistische
gesellschaft eigentlich ist es auch eine
sehr komplexe gesellschaft mit mit
verschiedenen schichtungen mit
verschiedenen interessen also mich noch
etwas gerne etwas zu den kosten sagen
die kopten hat mir die das militär sehr
unterstützt und haben zu anfang sogleich
nach den 30er jahren großen preis dafür
bezahlt es wurden in ganz ägypten wurden
kirchen angezündet klöster und so weiter
ich frage mich einfach wo damals die
ägyptische polizei war die ihr jetzt so
schützend diesen diesen verfassungs
vorgang
gesichert hat nicht und für mich wäre
dann wirklich eine die sehen sich jetzt
auch als gewinner natürlich für mich
wäre in der zukunft eben eine wirkliche
einbindung auch eine einbindung der
kopten in alle regierungs gremien das
militär ist zum beispiel eine
institution die für kopten bis zu einem
gewissen ab einem gewissen grad gar
nicht zugänglich ist nicht auch höhere
positionen in der politik ist knapp
unter mubarak immer so ein zwei alibi
minister die wahren kosten die hatten
rossis die nicht so wichtig sind
genug bier zum beispiel die libysche
bevölkerung die bevölkerung auf dem
sinai nicht also gibt die
landbevölkerung die auch unterschiedlich
ist das delta oberägypten
eine es ist eine föderation ja von
menschen und es ist wirklich die frage
inwiefern die sollten eigentlich alle
angebundenen eingebunden seien jetzt wer
jetzt die gewinner sind das ist klar die
polizei die natürlich wieder wieder dort
ist wo sie vorher gestalten ist nämlich
mit sehr viel macht ausgestattet und das
ist zum teil auch gut so wir haben ja
eine eine eine sicherheitssituation in
ägypten in den letzten drei jahren also
was praktisch keine polizei gab die hat
sich zurückgezogen
die polizei ist wieder vermehrt auf den
straßen es wird die sicherheit ist
besser geworden dass dass es tatsächlich
so also sieht sich eine gewinnerin na ja
und das problem ist dass vielleicht eben
auch die repräsentanten des alten
regimes wieder beginnen sich sozusagen
in position zu setzen ob die sich
etablieren können zb in einer parlament
situation das wird sich zeigen ob sie
könnten zu den gewinnern werden wir
haben die muslimbrüder über die ablösung
gesprochen werfen beim blick auf die
ganze region wo ergibt mittendrin liegt
dass es eine karte die ihr grüner desto
höher der anteil an muslimen muslimen
zeigt also die islamische welt
jedenfalls in dieser region und in
vielen dieser länder gab es hebungen was
hat jetzt herr schulze diese ablösung
der muslimbrüder für auswirkungen dieser
region gehabt
dass nämlich dazu zwei dinge sagen der
erste punkt ist die revolten in der
arabischen welt sind nicht in
irgendeiner art und weise erst man mit
mit dem islam in verbindung zu bringen
gewesen ursprünglichen das heißt sie
finden vor allen dingen oder fanden in
denen ländern in der arabischen welt
statt die bei einer alte republikanische
ordnung aus der zeit nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg stammen das sind tunesien
ägypten libyen syrien
teilweise jahren also politisch ebenso
alte versteinerte geschlossene
gesellschaften gewesen militär
gesellschaften gewesen die durch alte
republikanische ordnung entstanden die
monarchien sind einem blauen auge davon
gekommen
das heißt in den wohlig in monarchien
bis auf bahrain auf das mit dem
sonderfall dahin hatte es im grunde
keine solchen großen legitimationskrise
gegeben dort sind die an
auseinandersetzungen völlig anders
verlaufen bei auto hatten
integrationsprozess geführt um man hat
ein integrationsprozess geführt ja daran
ihn auch also dort lief es anders und
gibt die gewinner sind die monarchie die
verlierer sind die alten körper blicken
mit dem sturz von mosley hat sich jetzt
eine neue situation ergeben dass die
politischen islamischen institutionen
offenbar ihre macht und ihre
möglichkeiten völlig überschätzt haben
dass sie deutlich an legitimität
verloren haben und das war ich weiß
jetzt bis in die türkei
wo dann der
ministerpräsident erdogan in der türkei
plötzlich ist darunter leben leiden muss
das in ägypten die muslimbrüder gestürzt
worden sind und er jetzt im grunde in
eine legitimationskrise geraten ist weil
die muslimbrüder in ägypten gezeigt
haben ja wo ein land hinkommen kann wenn
es so weiter geht und wenn erdogan so
weitermacht wird er vielleicht einen
ägypten erleben und in tunesien haben
die muslimbrüder gezeigt dass sie lieber
in bis ins zweite glied zurücktreten
stadt das politische spiel weiter zu
spielen und haben eine verfassung
zugestimmt
die aus der sicht des politischen islam
völlig inakzeptabel ist weil sie völlig
liberal ist modern ist und völlig den
standards einer zivilgesellschaft
entspricht also die verlierer des ganzen
spiels in der letzten zeit ist die
islamische mittelklasse ist die
mittelklasse die bislang im bürgertum
verankert gewesen ist im mittleren
bürgertum auch bei der unternehmerschaft
teilweise die von der islamischen
situation profitiert haben und diese
verlierer schafft der steht jetzt im
grunde eine kleine gewinner schaftlichen
über das sind die ganzen von
ultra-religiösen verbände die nun
plötzlich unabhängig von jeglicher
staatsordnung zu beginnen zu agieren wie
in syrien oder im irak
die
die muslimbrüder ich verfolge sie sehr
intensiv seit 2005 seit sie damals das
erste mal im ägyptischen parlament 80
sitze erobert haben und bin mit all
diesen leuten die jetzt in gefängnisse
mit bildern und karten ich kann mich
erinnern ich habe die damals getroffen
in ihrem ersten kleinen büro in
roda und
die aufgabe wäre jetzt schon ist er
schon es wäre schon eigentlich jetzt
eine aufforderung an die muslimbrüder
einmal in sich zu gehen und ihre ganze
ihre ganzen theorien einmal zu
überdenken und zu öffnen und zu
aktualisieren ich meine dieser gibt
theorien die ideologie die sind in sich
geschlossen ist's ein
patriarchalischer des kurses ist ein von
religiös getränkter diskurs und begriffe
wie demokratie demokratie ist nur dann
wichtig für die muslimbrüder wenn sie an
die macht kommen aber was eben
mitbestimmung wie das herr schulze
gesagt ob das einbinden einer
gesellschaft ich kann mich erinnern ich
habe damals militär geht er jetzt im
gefängnis gefragt ich bin eine säkuläre
ägypterin was können sie mir bieten wenn
sie als muslimbruder einmal an die macht
kommen oder ins parlament er konnte mit
den begriffen gar nicht anfangen ja also
hier wäre wäre das wäre sehr notwendig
eine selbstkritische haltung einzunehmen
nur werden sie das im moment nicht tun
weil sie natürlich als märtyrer dastehen
das haben natürlich diese verfolgungen
oder diese mit
sich gebracht es gibt aber jüngere eine
jüngere generation unter den
muslimbrüdern die sehr wohl bereit wäre
einen neuen weg zu gehen es gibt in
ägypten zum beispiel zwei gruppierungen
ein paar jahren astrid das ist eine
kleine partei und es gibt kein besonders
die eigentlich dieser dieser sehr
strengen hingegen rhetorik absprechen
wollen nur wie groß die unterstützung
ist innerhalb der bruderschaft also sie
sagen durchaus spürbar sind die
konsequenzen dieser politischen ablösung
dieses machtverlust der muslimbrüder sie
schildern jetzt diese bewegung ein
phänomen oder der ägyptische
islamwissenschaftler inzwischen
gestorben ist abschluss seit jahren und
sind immer auch begegnet er
war auch bei uns in der sendung hat
geschildert ja die muss brüder zu seiner
lebzeit wie er da aufgewachsen ist in
ägypten aus den ferien von 50er 60er
jahren das war so eine bewegung soziale
bewegung der und sich um die leute in
den dörfern gekümmert ich hab so böse
ein bisschen an die heilsarmee gedacht
vielleicht ein gewagter vergleich aber
womit hängt denn diese politisierung wie
kommt es dazu dass die bis hin zur
präsidentschaft gekommen sind das ist
auch passiert sie haben ja das haut noch
mit also dass das höre ich auch von den
kunden von der älteren generation ich
genau das nicht das also dass menschen
waren die gab es gar freizeitclubs zum
beispiel in den dörfern wo die jungs
billiard gespielt haben oder fußball
gespielt haben und wo dieser diese diese
diese politische rhetorik oder diese auf
dieser politische anspruch gar nicht
vorhanden ist wie gesagt ein bisschen
eine art teils armeematerial karitatives
gemacht was er nach wie vor auch der
fall ist ja diese radikalisierung hat
sicher damit zu tun dass sie natürlich
ab 52 in den untergrund gegangen sind
sie wurden ja in die gefängnisse
gesteckt und da hat das wäre eine sehr
sehr lange zeit von gefängnis erfahrung
dann eine kurze rehabilitation
unterseite und dann wiederum gefängnisse
zum teil auch führer die die
radikale schriften zum teil hatten wie
seit gut wie zum beispiel ein
ägyptischer muslimbruder also diese
radikalisierung unterstützung auch von
den von der natürlich von den von den
islamischen ländern das dazu geführt hat
dass eben eine abzusagen eine sehr sehr
enge ein enges verständnis
stattgefunden hat und eben diese das
gefühl eben in der verantwortung in der
entschuldigung der bevölkerung verankert
gewesen zu sein was sie auch waren bis
vor der revolution durch ihre
karitativen ansichten und dass dann die
hoffnung hatten dass in politik
umzumünzen was ihnen ja gelungen ist
aber sie haben nichts erreicht und ich
auch sagen je höher der drucker vergeben
wurde von außen sechs tage krieg usw
desto mehr ist dieses nationale element
gewachsen desto mehr hat für die 1 nach
eben die religion dann eine rolle
gespielt
ich lieber keinen direkten zusammenhang
die muslimbrüder werden oft heute als
eine art von geschlossene organisation
wahrgenommen die in der lage wären
bestimmt keine bestimmte agenda
umzusetzen und ich finde es etwas
verkürzt sie auf die sieben auf ihrer
karitativen
sozialarbeit zweiter zu reduzieren dass
sich krankenhäuser machen ihre heimat
und alles mögliche was sie inszenieren
die müssen wurde repräsentieren in das
einzig in ägypten existierende
sogenannte sozial moralischen ein sozial
moralisches milieus einmal zu wenig wie
man wegen der katholizismus im rheinland
in deutschland oder in bayern das heißt
man muss nicht unbedingt überzeugt da
muslim sein um den muslim bruderschaften
das abzugewinnen sondern man lebt
einfach in den traditionen in ordnung
und an den wertvorstellungen die durch
diese gemeinschaft mit dem tablett
worden sind sie sind ein
wertkonservativer in ägypten das sozial
stabil ist so dass manche heute sagen
können schon mein großvater war bei den
muslimbrüdern das heißt also dass die
partie zurück das hat man früher sein
könnten das heißt also man hat so etwas
wie eine eine eine familiengeschichte
die sich mit der muslimbruderschaft
verbindet man muss nicht mitglied sein
es ist einfach er ein netzwerk ein
milieu von menschen die sich eine einer
gemeinsamen wertkonservativen
orientierung bedienen und sie auch das
anerkennen in dem moment wo sich diese
wert konzept die wertkonservative
haltung als eine politische partei
formiert dann gibt es einen bruch es hat
ja dann auch die muslimbrüder gar nicht
als mussten bürger als partei entstanden
sind sondern sich eine neue plattform
geschaffen haben die freiheit und
gerechtigkeitspartei mit der sie
versuchten dann eine ihre klientel zu
mobilisieren
und diese sehr undurchsichtige
strukturen dazu geführt dass er als
politische partei sie natürlich er soll
sein die ideologischen programmatische
aussagen wir mussten wieder übersetzten
im
politischen willensbildungsprozess und
weniger die interessen die sich
sozusagen aus dem sozialen leben aus den
milieus heraus ergeben haben
das hat dann schon zur folge gehabt dass
die da so eine art von entflechtung
stattgefunden hat zwischen elite der
muslimbruderschaft auf der einen seite
und den millionen und millionen menschen
die irgendwie den muslimbrüdern etwas
abgewinnen die in diese mühle und
stellen das zeigt jetzt gut die
entwicklung der letzten jahre noch mal
auf diese karte der islamischen welt an
können wir sagen dass bis ins zwanzigste
jahrhundert hinein das kolonial geprägt
ist vereinfacht gesagt könnte man sagen
die engländer und die franzosen sich
gegen da aufgefallen da gibt man lange
eine eigentliche kolonie herr schulze
sie sagen in ihrem werk geschichte der
islamischen welt den zwanzigsten
jahrhundert der europäische blick auf
die islamische welt ist bis heute
kolonial geprägt wie ist das zu
verstehen
dass wir in erster linie so zu verstehen
dass wir in erster linie
die konflikte die sozialen und auch die
teilweise politischen konflikte in der
islamischen welt in der arabischen welt
danach beurteilen inwiefern die staaten
die dort existieren
erhalten bleiben inwiefern sie gut
geführt werden wenn gefahren sie eine
stabile regierung haben und ähnliches
das war typisch nachteil nach den
revolten
2011 wurde man in den medien meist
gefragt wer wird der nächste starker
mann und
die antwort war eigentlich die ich hoffe
keiner so waren meist die stimmung in
der bevölkerung sie hatten einfach die
nase voll davon gehabt dass sie von
starken männern regiert werden sie
wollten einfach sich selbst regieren das
heißt sie als teile der gesellschaft
wollten endlich den staat definieren und
der staat sollte nicht mehr definieren
was die gesellschaft zu sein also dieses
umkehr bild aber der westen er war nicht
in der lage die im grunde das
aufzugreifen sondern sie erwarteten eine
stabile politische führung die ein wenig
realismus zulässt und dann ist die sache
schon in ordnung der verdacht nicht
natürlich da dass das deshalb auch
gesagt wird damit die
geschäftsbeziehungen wohl gut weiter
funktionieren aber das war eigentlich
nicht der kern der revolte der ire
wollte wollte genau das gegenstück sie
wollte endlich eine art von befreiung
von der vormundschaft des status
herbeiführen der staat soll nicht mehr
die regeln für die gesellschaft
definieren die politik sollte nicht mehr
im dienste des staates stehen sondern
die politik sollte im dienste einer sehr
sehr unterschiedlichen landschaft von
anschauen meinung in der gesellschaft
existieren und das sollte das sollte die
revolte herbeiführen und da hat der
westen glaube ich mit seinem alten
kolonialen blick
gar teilweise auch der arabischen welt
ein bärendienst erwiesen indem er immer
wieder gefordert habe und die politische
stabilität herbeizuführen mein gott ein
land das sich endlich von ihrer
staatlichen bevormundung befreit das
braucht die haare um ein demokratisches
system von unten nach oben aufzubauen
auf der kommunalen ebene in den
stadtteilen in den vierteln wo dann auch
unterschiedliche willensbildungsprozesse
auch sich abbilden gemeinde
organisationen das brauche ich die haare
und das braucht natürlich auch das
braucht natürlich keine eine politische
bildung und eine alu kritikfähigkeit
also man muss konsensfähig sein man muss
lernen zu streiten man muss lernen eben
zu streiten und als freunde auseinander
zu gehen und das sind alles dinge die
die nicht im kanon sehen sich sagen im
kanon der der der der der inhalte die
wir in der schule lernen die wir in der
familie lernen in der familie ist der
vater in der regel das oberhaupt der
familie in der schule ist es der lehrer
an der universität dieses der professor
ist jemand immer jemand über einem dem
mann gehorsam zollen muss und dieses
diese autoritätsgläubigkeit die
natürlich anerzogen ist nicht die die
wird anerzogen es gilt die um zu rücken
meiner meinung nach und ja da war dazu
braucht es natürlich eine eine eine
größere tragfähigere zivile zivile
gesellschaft ich mich noch etwas zu
diesem kolonial
diskurs sagen also was jetzt interessant
ist also vor allem nach der nach dem
sturz von muss sie hat sich ägypten
eigentlich von der welt sehr alleine
gelassen gefühlt weil eben natürlich
alle länder von einem militärputsch
gesprochen haben und
es gab dann aus diese diese
ägyptische fernsehen und auch die
privaten sender die auf ihren auf den
bildschirmen jeweils eine 1 schrift
eingeblendet company to terrorism
also man wollte den welt erklären nein
das ist kein putsch das ist jetzt
wirklich der wille des volkes und wir
bestimmen jetzt selber was wir wollen
nicht amerika nicht eben die welt die
gewisse zu seinen interessen hat in
ägypten und und was das jetzt eben die
stimmung die jetzt eben auch so im
rahmen jetzt dieser verfassungs
abstimmung sehr deutlich wird also wir
zeigen es euch wir zeigen jetzt da wird
wie ägypter bestimmen jetzt selber was
wir wollen ja und ihr könnt nicht von
uns verlangen dass wir sozusagen er
bilden dass ein teil unserer
gesellschaft
terroristen sind wir müssen etwas
dagegen unternehmen also es ist so eine
eine haltung von mir gegen die welt noch
mal zurück zu dieser islamischen welt
und abu saied der sagt ich überlege oft
wie aus dem glauben der muslime so viele
komplikationen erwachsen können der
islam ist ein einfacher glaube ohne
komplikationen sie gehören ja zu einem
forum für einen fortschrittlichen islam
warum ist das so kompliziert
ja das ist eine gute frage warum ist das
so kompliziert also ich glaube einfach
auch hier also meiner ganz persönlichen
erfahrung dass wir in der schule in der
familie in der gesellschaft in den jetzt
aus diesem kontext aus dem ich spreche
lernen dass wir das was was im koran
steht und was was in der summe steht
dass wir das einfach glauben und wir
dürfen es nicht hinterfragen ist es gibt
keine dass im moment des zweifels das
hinterfragen das kritische hinterfragen
und eventuell auch der moment zu sagen
ich möchte mich davon lösen oder ich
kann mit gewissen inhalten nicht mehr
leben und dieser druck geben es ist eine
rein normative angelegenheit geworden
die religion besteht nur noch eigentlich
aus der islam besteht nur noch aus
geburt noch nun an einheit unter frauen
und kanäle und das ist eine sehr sehr
große reduzierung doch eine einer einer
religion die ihr sehr sehr viel bewirkt
hat ich empfinde diesen umgebung als
großes problem und auch hier wieder die
autorität die uns sagt so musst du
denken so musst du sein dann bist du ein
guter muslim und reinigt bist du eben
kein guter muslim ich weiß für den
spezialisten ist das eine wahnsinns
frage aber der islam ich muss fünf dinge
beachten oder ob ich sie also das
glaubensbekenntnis das gebet almosen die
wallfahrt nach mekka was eigentlich
verkehrs ist sehr einfach das fasten
genau das fasten
das war es warm ist so kompliziert
geworden
vielleicht liegt das eben daran dass ein
wenig kompliziert ist
was wir heute erleben an
ein islamischer
vorstellungswelt sollten in keinem weise
versuchen in verbindung zu bringen was
das islamische eigentlich sei das lässt
sich überhaupt gar nicht definieren
müssen überhaupt nicht bestimmt es lässt
sich nicht zurück projizieren auf eine
zeit des propheten handelt aber sieht
man sehr kooperativ das passiert aber
wenn wir uns das anschauen wie das heute
wir was heute islam eigentlich ist wie
heute islam gelebt wird
völlig unterschiedlich von einer
säkularen einstellung hin bis zur ultra
religiösen einstellungen von
kampfverbänden in afghanistan pakistan
nordkorea oder auch immer so sehen wir
dass es so etwas wie eine repräsentation
eine einheit ein konsens darüber was
eigentlich das islamische islamisch
macht überhaupt gar nicht mehr
existieren also von einer einheitlichen
religionsgemeinschaft können wir
überhaupt gar nicht ausgehen sodass wir
auch nicht sagen können dass eine
bestimmte art von umgangsweise mit dem
islam immer gleich ist hinzu kommt das
zweite die
zeitgenössischen islam interpretationen
sind durchweg moderne interpretationen
das heißt interpretationen die darauf
beruhen eine bestimmte rolle der
religion in der gesellschaft zu weisen
sie können wird konservativ sein sie
können aber auch so ausgerichtet sein
dass gesagt wird der islam stelle die
alltags normen darsteller regeln für die
alltags normen da bis hin zu der
auffassung der islam erlaubt mir
persönlich die exekutive sogar die
durchsetzung bestimmter regeln bis hin
zur bekämpfung eines ungläubigen oder
was weiß ich alles also eigene kampf
gewaltig zu entwickeln das sind alles
sehr sehr moderne interpretationen wenn
man allein kurzen blick zurückwirft und
fragt seit wann gibt es im islam
eigentlich über wann wurde in der
islamischen tradition zum ersten mal
eine frau regnen und sucht gesteinigt
das kann man sehr genau datieren das war
1678 das hat einen allen jahr einen
siebzehnten jahrhundert findet das zum
ersten mal statt und arabische autoren
derzeit schreiben von einem skandal
sowas darf es überhaupt nicht geben das
ist nicht islamisch das war der konsens
im siebzehnten jahrhundert dass so etwas
nie passieren dürfen auch wenn es in der
propheten tradition als solche regel
irgendwo ab barriere und jetzt finden
wir im zwanzigsten jahrhundert in
pakistan oder in afghanistan so etwas
wie ein konsens zur dann
selbstverständlich dann muss seine frau
gestalten oder soll den oder ein
abtrünniger vom islam seit wann wird ein
abtrünniger vom islam mit dem tode
tatsächlich bedroht oder auch gar
bestraft erst seit dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert das heißt wir haben es mit
sehr modernen fragen zu tun mit modernen
situation zu tun und man müsste sich
eigentlich überlegen und fragen was ist
eigentlich in der moderne so schwierig
dass solche religionsformen entstehen
und nicht andersherum fragen wieso ist
die religions- form des islam so wie wir
sie heute erleben aus der eigenen
tradition heraus zu verstehen also die
moderne erschafft sich religionsformen
die postmoderne erschafft sich neue
religionsformen und das islamische feld
ist nur
ein forum auf dem sich diese neuen
religionsformen immer wieder neue heraus
entwickeln und neu ausgestaltet wir
nehmen sie aus bestimmten gründen
besonders radikal war in der islamischen
welt man könnte genauso gut in anderen
ländern schauen und sehen dass es dort
auch probleme gibt ich habe jetzt diese
vielfalt eindrücklich geschildert auch
das wechselverhältnis von
gesellschaftlichen politischen und eben
diesen religiösen vorgängen wir haben
über einen konflikt noch nicht
gesprochen syrien
eine internationale geberkonferenz hat
den letzten tagen 24 milliarden dollar
gesprochen mal auf dem papier für die
bedürftigsten
über den frieden wird gestritten wird
verhandelt sehen wir ein abschnitt zur
rolle der islamisten als ein beitrag der
sendung 10 vor 10 von vor wenigen tagen
von sitzen januar 2014
sie können die gewalt in ihrer heimat
nicht mehr ertragen und fliehen iraker
die ramadi und falludscha verlassen weil
sie dort ständigem terror radikaler
islamisten ausgesetzt sind
wir sind alle zusammen geflohen die
ganze familie auch mein mann und meine
kinder sind dabei
gott will dass es keine unterschiede
gibt zwischen den verschiedenen
volksgruppen hier wir sind alle gegen
terroristen extremisten und kriminelle
die
straßen in ramadi sind leergefegt und
gezeichnet von den kämpfen der
vergangenen tage
schuld sind die terrorgruppen des
sogenannten islamischen staates im irak
und syrien kurz ease die islamistischen
banden haben sich in syrien und dem irak
in den vergangenen monaten extrem
ausgebreitet
hier halten isis terroristen ein
standgericht in hk die gefangenen werden
sie später hinrichten das video stellen
die islamisten selber ins internet
dieses ist in syrien und dem irak aktiv
das ziel der gruppe ist es aus beiden
ländern einen islamischen gottesstaat zu
machen in den letzten monaten haben sich
die terroristen im herzen der beiden
länder einen streifen der macht erkämpft
der kopf der gruppe ist abu bakr al
baghdadi der behauptet dass seine
familie direkt vom propheten mohammed
abstamme für den kampf gegen die
extremisten will die us-regierung dem
irak nun waffen liefern
wir werden den irakischen streitkräften
weitere hellfire-raketen liefern es hat
sich erwiesen dass diese raketen ein
gutes mittel sind die rückzugsräume der
islamisten zu zerstören
die irakischen streitkräfte greifen die
terroristen aus der luft an doch
militärische interventionen werden nicht
genügen um die isis dauerhaft
zurückzudrängen
vl worte was braucht es doch geworfen
na ja
es geht wieder eigentlich um diese
landkarte meiner meinung nach nicht das
wird hier syrien
diese ganzen
einmischungen und diese ganzen sozusagen
internationalen interventionen die sich
darauf beschränken waffen zu liefern die
eine partei oder an die andere ist
irgendwie habe ich mit einem
stellvertreterkrieg zu tun und
eigentlich auch hier als diese der
aufstand in syrien begann der begann
ganz harmlos mit kindern die am ende
etwas gemalt haben oder gesprengt haben
und diese dimension
begleitet einem irgendwie aus der hand
also man wo soll man hier noch anfangen
ich bin sehr sehr sehr sehr skeptisch
gibt es einen ausweg
1 auswärts persönlich mehr also stärke
die situation für die syrische
bevölkerung ist dermaßen katastrophal
dass das land als land politisch kaum
noch mit zurück konstruieren ist ich
würde auch ich denke auch dass jeder
politische konsens der jetzt in bezug
auf syrien geschaffen wird das ist nicht
das problem innerhalb der nächsten zehn
jahre lösen wird das heißt es werden
weiter massive auseinandersetzung im
land stattfinden das zeigt noch einmal
sehr deutlich die syrische regierung und
das syrische regime hat es eben nicht
geschafft so einen starken positiven
gesellschafts konsens zu entwickeln der
es erlauben würde ein regime wechsel
durchzuführen und so darüber an dem dann
das land nicht zerbricht sondern das
regime der assad familie hat dazu
geführt dass im grunde die leute sich
nicht mehr mit ihrer eigenen sozialen
gesellschaftlichen situation vollkommen
positive identität indentifizieren so
dass das land auseinander geflogen ist
die bevölkerung ist auseinandergebrochen
das heißt auch viel viel mehr als in
ägypten noch viel mehr als in libyen
haben wir es hier mit einem
zusammenbruch an der gesellschaftlichen
ordnung zu tun die der kitt der
gesellschaftliche kitt
den gibt es im augenblick nicht es gibt
nicht so etwas wie eine zukunft
vorstellung für syrien wo sagen sie
sagen könnte wenn wir uns alle auf den
punkt einigen können wir wieder hoben in
einer gemeinsamen ordnung leben diesen
punkt gibt es nicht und zu lange haben
da auch die westlichen länder tragen im
grunde damit gelebt dass es die syrische
regime gibt sie kommen zu spät ist viel
zu spät und der zusammenbruch der
syrischen ordnung und der wohl
anstehende zusammenbruch der irakischen
ordnung werden dazu führen dass in
diesem land und konnte die alten
staatlichen strukturen erst mal völlig
wackelig sind völlig instabil bleiben
und wie sich diese dann wieder
rekonstruieren lassen ich weiß es nicht
einfach nur waffen zu liefern das wird
die überhaupt keinen punkt mehr bringen
dieses hat etwa 15 bis 20 tausend man
die jetzt durch die wüste dort herum
marodieren diese 15 bis 20 tausend
menschen werden zunehmend noch durch
andere aus ganz anderen teilen der welt
aufgestockt es ist eine ganz kleine
minderheit aber die so stark so militant
auftritt dass sie zu einem machtfaktor
im lande werden können den zu besiegen
militärisch zu besiegen das wage ich zu
bezweifeln das hat auch in afghanistan
nicht geklappt das hat in somalia nicht
geklappt das wird in pakistan nicht
klappen also insofern ist wüsste ich
nicht welcher konsens in syrien das land
retten kann sie sprechen die
internationalisierung an der islamische
zentralrat der schweiz hat auch syrische
rebellen unterstützt einzelne exponenten
dieses zentralrat haben arbeit studiert
betrieb sie das
es bedrückt mich natürlich schon wenn
also bestimmt
wenn menschen die an schweizer
universitäten ausgebildet werden doch an
einem sehr reduzierten blick auf diese
vision verhältnisse haben und dort dann
relativ willkürlich eine politische
organisation unterstützen die
agrarischen waren es in dem fall also
die freien syriens waren sie in diesem
falle
natürlich kann man kann niemandem
absprechen eine politische partei zu
ergreifen für sion die frage ist nur
inwiefern das nicht auch dazu führt den
gesellschafts konsens weiter in syrien
zu untergraben die arabischen also die
gruppe die vom zentralrat mit
unterstützt worden ist ist eine gruppe
die man eher interpretieren kann also
etwas billiger militante flügel der
muslimbruderschaft also in syrien hat es
eine sehr schwacher muslimbruderschaft
gegeben und sie bilden im grunde so
etwas wie alt die muslimbruderschaft in
syrien ab also sie sind nicht mit dieses
gleichzusetzen
das da trennen sie welten zwischen
diesen beiden verbänden und insofern
muss man aufpassen genauer schauen wer
da wen eigentlich unterstützt wer dafür
wenn das wort reden ja mit der aktuellen
situation ergibt angefangen sind über
die islamische welt verschiedene
konfliktherde jetzt zum schluss dann
über den islam nach syrien gekommen wenn
wir so einen kurzen ausblick wagen die
wird es denn weitergehen mit der
ägyptischen revolution
ja das ist eine offene frage ich glaube
die kann jetzt niemand wirklich
schlüssig beantworten für mich wäre das
schlimmste szenario
folgendes wenn jetzt im nachklang der
verfassung bei dem präsident bei dem
tollen bei den parlaments
parlamentswahlen sich eine koalition
ergeben würde zwischen militärvertretern
des ehemaligen regimes und den
salafisten das wäre für mich dann
endgültig eigentlich der tod jeglichen
fortschritt oder jeglicher demokratie
demokratiefähigkeit des landes
der schuld so wird die arabische
revolution oder man sprach vom
arabischen frühling weiter oh ja da wird
sehr lange weiterleben noch wird
natürlich nicht als frühling weiterleben
aber wird weiterleben in der ungeheuren
mobilisation der bevölkerung das heißt
die bevölkerung ist aus ihren privaten
räumen auf die straße getreten und sie
hat gelernt dass es
das durchaus etwas erreichbar ist wird
man auf die straße tritt und die
möglichkeit zu tausenden oder gar
hunderttausende oder gar millionen
einfach sich zu versammeln und dadurch
irgendetwas zu erreichen nämlich mal in
ägypten kurz zwei präsidenten zu stürzen
das ist schon eine sache und das wird
sich aber mubarak hat man geschafft also
man könnte auch sie schaffen das heißt
also die diese erfahrung dass man
sozusagen das die gesellschaft selbst
einen willen entwickeln kann und die
gesellschaft selbst wenn sie in
irgendeiner form sich in ihrer
pluralität anerkennt auch das regime
stürzen kann diese erfahrung lässt sich
glaube ich die arabische welt nicht mehr
nehmen
die iraner schauen zum beispiel sehr
neidisch auf die arabische welt und
sagen mensch wie habt ihr denn das
hingekriegt warum haben wir das 2009
nicht geschafft also insofern wird die
arabische welt schon als ein bisschen
als avantgarde angesehen sie sind stolz
darauf was sie alles für vorbilder
geschaffen haben bis hin die art und
weise wie in der ukraine öffentlich
jetzt vorgegangen wird all das kommt
irgendwie aus dem arabischen frühling
und darauf sind sie so stolz und ich
glaube diese erfahrung die werden sich
die menschen in der arabischen welt
niemals mehr nehmen lassen und das weiß
wohl auch in zukunft jedes regime dass
jedes regime das in ägypten herrschen
wird weiß dass es irgendwann mal das
volk als opposition gegen sich haben
kann vor allem die jüngeren vor allem
jüngere generation die das eben
mitgetragen hat in tunesien hat es
begonnen mit der verbrennung eines
selbstverbrennung eines gemüsehändlers
ein öffnungs blick
als
als der gemüsehändler sich verbrannte
hat er nichts hinterlassen
hat nichts unterlassen aus asche aber
hat nicht an verbrannten körper
als sich
alsdann diese auseinandersetzung statt
gefunden haben um die frage sollen wir
das nachmachen sollen wir also zu sagen
uns noch mal selbst verbrennen
energie in ägypten als solche versuche
den mann fühlte sich erinnert an die
situation bei 169 in der
entscheidungsgewalt netzwerk muss
ähnliche
mitmach so eine ähnliche situation
gegeben hat nur es gab eben kein
politisches programm das verknüpft war
mit der selbstverbrennung es gab keine
aussage ich will damit etwas für die
gesellschaft erreichen als jan palach
sicheren angezündet hat 1969 hat es
gemacht mit einer aktentasche mit einer
öffentlichen erklärung wohl drin stand
was er wollte
in tunesien hat das nicht statt das
heißt niemand sprach für die bevölkerung
sondern die bevölkerung sprachen sich
selbst und das hat grund die arabische
volk immer getragen die islamische welt
in bewegung herzlichen dank herr schulze
viel sympathie für dieses gespräch
dieses gespräch finden sie
selbstverständlich auch auf unserer
website
nächsten sonntag sprechen wir über das
erinnern und vergessen welchen sinn hat
das vergessen fürs individuum für die
gesellschaft antworten darauf in einer
woche jetzt gleich aber gibt's auf
entdeckungsfahrt
zeitgenössische künstler aus der schweiz
was treibt sie an wonach suchen sie wann
sind sie glücklich ein film unter
anderem mit maria pia bornim ii und sus
platz